folks an inspection of the fossil record
over the last 178 million years which is
since mammals first appeared reveals
that the average mammalian species
that's where all that were all mammals
exists for about a million years before
it evolves into something else or else
vanishes into extinction
and
of our allotted lifespan of a million
years humanity homo sapiens has been
around for about 200 000 years in other
words we're still collectively a
youngster
if you imagine that million years as the
lifespan of an individual human being
about 80 years then we're now sweet 16.
we've come to that fateful age when we
know roughly how to drive and we know
how to unlock the drinks cabinet and to
engage in all sorts of activity that is
not only a potentially embarrassing but
also terminal for ourselves and and
others in the words of the oxford
philosopher toby ord we're just old
enough to get ourselves
into serious trouble
and
i'm afraid we believe we still cling
with parts of our minds to the infantile
belief that the world was made for our
gratification and pleasure and we
combine this narcissism
with an assumption of our own
immortality we believe that someone else
will clear up the mess because that is
what someone else has always done and we
trash our habitats again and again with
the inductive reasoning that we've got
it we've got away with it so far and
therefore we'll get away with it again
my friends the adolescence
of humanity
is coming to an end and must come to an
end we approaching that critical turning
point in less than two months in just
over 40 days
when we must show
that we are capable of learning and
maturing and finally taking
responsibility for the destruction we
are inflicting
not just upon our planet
but
upon ourselves
it's time for humanity
to grow up
it's time for us to listen to the
warnings of the scientists and if you
look at covid
if you want to see an example of the
gloomy scientist being proved right
it's time for us to grow up and
understand who we are and what we are
doing
the world
this precious blue sphere with its
eggshell crust and wisp of an atmosphere
is not some indestructible toy some
bouncy plastic romper room against which
we can hurl ourselves to our hearts
content daily weekly we are doing such
irreversible damage that long before a
million years are up we will have made
this beautiful planet effectively
uninhabitable
not just for us but for many other
species
and that is why
the glasgow cop 26 summit is the turning
point for humanity we must limit the
rise in temperatures whose appalling
effects were visible even this summer to
1.5 degrees we we must come together in
a collective coming of age
we must show
that we have the maturity and wisdom
to act and we can
even in this past 16 years as it were
this feckless youth that we've just
passed we've shown our skill
we've harnessed clean energy from wind
and wave and sun we've released energy
from within the atom itself and from
hydrogen we found ways to store that
energy in increasingly capacious
batteries and even
in molten salt
we have the tools for a green industrial
revolution
we've got the kit
but time
is desperately short
two days ago here in in new york
we had a session in which we heard
from the leaders of the nations most
threatened by climate change
the marshall islands the maldives mr
president bangladesh and many others
and they spoke of the hurricanes and the
flooding and the fires
caused by the extreme meteorological
conditions the world is already seeing
and the tragedy
is that because of our past in action
there are further rises in temperatures
that are already baked in
and my friends baked is the word if we
keep on the current track then the
temperatures will go up by 2.7 degrees
or more by the end of the century never
mind what that will do uh to the ice
floes
dissolving like ice in your martini here
in
new york we will see
desertification
drought
crop failure
and mass movements of humanity on a
scale
not seen before
not because of some unforeseen
natural event or disaster
but because of us
because of what we are doing now and our
grandchildren
will know
that we are the culprits and they will
know
that we knew
that we were warned
and they will know that it was this
generation that came center stage
to speak
and act on behalf of them on behalf of
posterity
and that we missed our cue
and they will ask themselves what kind
of people we were
to be so selfish
and so
short-sighted
in just 40 days time we need the world
to come to glasgow to make the
commitments necessary and we're not
talking i'm afraid about stopping the
rise in temperatures we can't do that
it's too late to stop the rise in
temperatures
but to restrain that growth as i say to
1.5
degrees
and that means we need to pledge
collectively
to achieve
carbon neutrality net zero by the middle
of the century and that will be an
amazing moment if we can do it
because it will mean that for the first
time in centuries humanity is no longer
adding to the budget of carbon in the
atmosphere
no longer thickening that invisible
quilt that is warming the planet and
it's fantastic that we now have
countries uh uh here at the the un
representing 70 of the world's gdp who
are committed to this net zero objective
70 of the world gdp and i'm proud to say
when my friend and colleague
sharma the president designate of cop 26
began his his mission his peregrinations
around the world that number was only 30
of world gdp so we're getting that
is the point i'm making
and uh we can go further and if we are
going to stay off uh stave off these uh
these hikes
these rises in temperature
we must go further and we must go far
faster
we need all countries every single one
of you
to step up and commit to very
substantial reductions by 2030
and i absolutely convinced i
passionately believe that we can do it
by making commitments in four areas
and i want you to remember them coal
cars cash and trees coal cars cash and
trees very simple
i'm not one of those environmentalists
by the way who takes a a moral pleasure
in excoriating humanity for its excess i
don't see the green movement as a
pretext for a wholesale assault on
capitalism far from it
the whole experience of the kovid
pandemic is that the way to fix the
problem is through science and
innovation the breakthroughs and the
investments that are made possible by
capitalism and free markets and it's
through our promethean faith
in new green technology that we are
cutting emissions in the in the uk when
i was a kid we produced almost 80
percent
of our electricity
from coal
i know that some of the some of you here
tonight rely very heavily on coal
but in the in the uk
that percentage is now down to two
percent or less and coal will be gone
altogether
from our energy production by 2024
we've put in great forests of beautiful
wind turbines
on the drowned prairies of dogoland
between
britain and holland
in the north sea in fact we produce so
much offshore wind that i'm thinking of
changing my name in honour of the god of
the north wind to boreas johnson there
you go there's a
shove in that classical illusion this
time of night to see if you're you're
you're paying attention folks uh and i
know uh that we're we're ambitious in
asking the developing world to end the
use of coal power by by 2040 and for the
developed world to do so by 2030 but the
experience of the uk shows that it can
be done
and profitably too
and i by the way i want to thank very
much president xi of china for what he
has just done to end china's
international financing of coal and i
hope china will now go further and phase
out the domestic use of coal as well
wouldn't that be a great thing
because the experience of the uk shows
that it can be done and when i was
elected mayor of london only a mere 13
years ago i was desperate to encourage
more electric vehicles and we we went
around the city putting in charging
points and i'm afraid to say
that in those days those charging points
were pretty lonely objects and not much
patternized but today
it's totally different
and the market for electric vehicles is
growing at an extraordinary pace maybe
two-thirds every year and nissan is
sufficiently confident now to invest a
billion pounds in a new ev factory plus
a gigafactory for batteries and that is
because
the government we have set the hard
deadline for the sale of new uh
hydrocarbon internal combustion engine
vehicles by 2030 the most aggressive
deadline in the whole of uh in the whole
of europe
and
again
we call on the world to come together to
drive this market in a
low carbon uh way drive this market so
that by 2040 there are
only
zero emission vehicles on sale anywhere
in the world and my point is that you
can make these cuts in pollution these
massive cuts in pollution and emissions
while driving jobs and growth we've cut
our greenhouse gas emissions by 44 in
the last 30 years while expanding our
gdp by 78 and we will now go further by
implementing one of the biggest
nationally determined contributions uh
currently being offered the
the national nationally determined
contribution uh is the is the ndc is the
pledge that in the run up to to cop
we're asking every country to make in
cutting carbon we're going to go down by
68
uh by 2030 68 cut
in carbon by 2030 compared to where we
were in 1990. we're making a big bet on
on hydrogen we're going to be expanding
our nuclear capacity and you can see the
logic of going for more uh renewables
when you can when you look at the spike
in uh in hydrocarbon prices uh
particularly uh particularly gas
we're helping people to reduce their own
household co2 by retrofitting their
homes and going for new sources of of
heating
we're working towards jet zero the first
large guilt-free carbon-free passenger
plane
and
we also recognize that this is not just
about
using technical fixes
technology to cut co2 we also need to
work together around the world to
restore the balance
between
humanity and nature a balance that's
obviously been proved so hopelessly out
of whack by the emergence of
a zoonotic pandemic for instance we need
to halt and reverse the loss of trees
and biodiversity uh by 2030. halton
reverse the loss of trees by 2030.
that's what we should do uh in uh the
pledge to do that at the at the cop in
just 40 days time and that's why we in
the uk are committed to beautifying the
landscape strengthening our protection
against flooding by planting millions
more trees beautiful trees that stop
soil erosion provide habitats for
insects and
birds and and mammals and which of
course help to to fix carbon in the
atmosphere we must also work towards the
crucial uh un con summit on biodiversity
in calming in china
and by the way on the on the subject of
planting trees uh we're going to do
millions in the uk but i was absolutely
blown away i i i invite everybody to
follow the example of imran khan of
pakistan who has pledged to plant 10
billion trees
in pakistan alone and he's going some
and
i think it's very important
that we in the developed world recognize
our obligation
to help less developed countries down
this path in all these in all these
technologies and uh
we've got to be honest with the in the
united kingdom we in britain
started
this industrial
hydrocarbon-based revolution
we were the first to send great puffs of
acrid smoke into the heavens on a scale
big enough to derange the natural order
and
though we were in fact of course doing
something rather wonderful in one sense
we were setting and train a new era of
technology that was itself to lead to a
massive global reduction in poverty
emancipating billions of people around
the world
the industrial revolution was a good
thing fundamentally but we were also
unwittingly beginning to quilt the great
tea cozy of carbon dioxide around the
world and
so we understand that when the
developing world
looks to us uh to help we must we must
take our responsibilities
and that's why two years ago when i
last came here
mr president to anger i committed
that the uk would provide 11.6 billion
pounds to help the rest of the world to
tackle climate change
and
i want you to know
that in spite of all the pressures on
our finances in the uk caused by kovid
we
have kept that promise
to the letter
and so i'm very pleased and encouraged
by some of the pledges we've heard here
at unger including from denmark
and now
a very substantial commitment from the
united states
that brings us within touching distance
of that 100 billion dollar pledge that
we need every year
but we must go further
and we've got to be clear that
government alone and government cash
alone is not going to be enough we must
work together so that the international
financial institutions the imf the world
the world bank are working with
governments around the world to leverage
in
the private sector
because it is the trillions of dollars
of private sector cash
that will enable developing nations and
the whole world all of us
to make the changes necessary
and to give an example it was the uk
government that set the the strike price
under the con contract for this
difference system the strike price for
the private sector to come in and
transform
our country into the the saudi arabia of
wind uh and if if you see what i mean
we don't resemble saudi arabia in many
ways but we in terms of of offshore wind
we have a fanta we have we produce more
offshore wind than any other country in
the world and only yesterday's uh
yesterday the uk's first sovereign green
bond raised 10 billion pounds on the
markets
on the markets from hard headed
investors who want to make money
and my point is that these investments
will not only help the countries of the
world to tackle climate change they will
produce
millions i mean literally in the decades
to come millions and millions of
high-wage high-skill jobs and today's
workforce and uh
the next generation
of green collar workers will have the
extra satisfaction
of knowing that they're not only doing
something useful and well remunerated
providing green energy
but also helping to save the planet at
the same time
every day uh green startups are
producing new ideas from feeding seaweed
to cows to restain their restrain their
traditional signs of digestive approval
to using
artificial intelligence and robotics to
enhance food production uh
put
capture co2 put it into uh into brownies
uh and so on
and it's these technological
breakthroughs that will cut the cost for
consumers so that we have nothing
to fear
and everything to gain from this green
industrial revolution
and when kermit the frog
kermit the frog
sang
it's not easy being green
you remember that one
i want you to know that he was wrong
he was wrong
it is
easy it's not any easy it's lucrative
and it's right to be green he'll bother
he's also unnecessarily rude to miss
piggy i thought uh kermit the frog
but it is easy uh to be green we have
the technology as we used to say when i
was a when i was a kid we can do it we
have so so in 40 days time we have the
choice before us
the the poet sophocles is often quoted
or often quoted by me anyway as saying
that there are many terrifying things in
the world
but none is more terrifying
than
mankind
and it's certainly true that uh
sophocles was was right in that sense
and though
our species is uniquely capable of our
own destruction and the destruction of
everything around us
but uh what what if you look at look at
the greek what sophocles actually said
was uh that man
polite dana kudan anthropu de notron
pele is what he said which is denotes
man is danos and da and terrifying isn't
quite right as a translation for denos
what what what sophomores really means
that mankind is humanity is awesome
we're both terrifying but also awesome
and i think he was right there
we have an awesome power to change
things
and to change things for the better
and an awesome power
to save ourselves
and in the next 40 days
we have to choose
the world has to choose
what kind of awesome
we're going to be
and
to get back to
my
metaphor of adolescence
i hope that cop 26
will be a 16th birthday party for
humanity in which which is not a uh not
miserable but a party in which we choose
to go up to to grow up
to recognize the scale of the challenge
that we faced and and to do what
posterity demands that we must and so i
invite you i invite the uh this great un
assembly uh in november
to come and take part
by your actions
in what i hope will be a a global coming
of age
and
to blow out the candles if you like blow
out the candles of a world on fire
that's what i think we should do so
thank you all very much thank you for
the pledges that you're making i hope
that you will uh you will increase them
and do what is necessary
mr president see you in glasgow thank
you